but we if you're with me I've got the
guns so that at least we can survive
yeah yeah all right I'm gonna be careful
scientists okay I'm gonna pretend that
didn't happen
[Laughter]
stop please I'm gonna move carefully
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
fire alarm fire alarm and a will take an
early scheduled break completely the
firearm fire when we look up into the
night sky on a bulbous summer night we
see millions of tiny spots of light each
one represents a High Noon which is the
center of a ger fascia solar system with
dozens of chunks revolving likley around
a distant Sun sometimes these Suns
expand and begin squelching their
neighbors soon they will become so big
they turn into chunga's eventually they
subside and becoming gourds giants or
perhaps black paintings our own planet
which we call Danny DeVito circles
around our thick Sun 11 times a year
there are eight other planets in our
solar system they are named Danny DeVito
Danny DeVito Danny DeVito Danny DeVito
Danny DeVito Danny DeVito Jupiter and
Mars you think you helped me you just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] there we go
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
bones the cupcake size - oh you're right
singing and flying on a carpet that was
heat on the carpet you can fly website
don't know
he doesn't need a carpet all right would
you like didn't take the conflict i'm
live right now there's like a bunch of
text like a real subtle sorry what were
you talking about keep going out oh no
that's not a thing is it I don't know
man
here we go what's the national anthem in
the name of our country I don't even
know man
how you make it up mark is the greatest
man in the world and the world is only
this dream we live til love that
delicious man we want him to rule our
lives he's the best in the world and
everybody loves him Oh
under worship him his Abbas its mark
applier is the best the best he's the
best he has a gun to the back of our
heads
anybody's the best how about da best
that's our national anthem
everybody eyes that in the next 30
minutes we're gonna have another we're
gonna have another go love it
we have another goal of it memorize it
if you don't memorize it you will be
shot I was about to say put it in your
[ __ ] but that doesn't seem good I
look soft what does that even mean
anyone who knows markiplier knows I'm
hard as nails
I'm hard as a rock I am so hard right
now
everyone knows this if you know this
about me you know that I am so [ __ ]
hard right now
oh there's someone in my building I am
dead no gun
Mozambique guide my hand I'm gonna [ __ ]
you up
coming to you it doesn't matter how many
they are I'm still gonna [ __ ] him up
with my mozi ah [ __ ] I was so close to
killing you hope you die in a fire
do you have any nice things to say about
Mark Waid yeah I've seen shorter people
so much for being here
moist grandmothers moist grandmothers ha
moist moist grandma
moist grandmothers cheered four hundred
bits said mark your mom is too cute
I ordinarily that'd be a nice comment
but coming from moist grandmothers huh
Oreo the kitty thanks for the hundred
business I had the ammo to get by okay
all right I got it
you didn't tell well [ __ ] you what the
[ __ ] you didn't test that I [ __ ] you
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] duck it's
[ __ ] what excuse the [ __ ] of one of
me extra [ __ ] his ski user you a kook
excuse a [ __ ] - what excact for
cocking you I did so good
I didn't know some words but I knew when
I was just [ __ ] [ __ ] duck are you
excuse the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] me me
I'm right you am wrong
[Applause]
is wrong you who is right made haha dumb
that's you me smart big smart now mind
you all of this started around 1:00 a.m.
so this is five and a half hours later
dude shows up in the house starts
cutting holes in the walls I'll yep your
walls wet miss me miss me now you gotta
kiss me
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we're trying to support each other here
with God yeah I don't support you guys
though I don't know it's against my
religion you write it just like sound
word popped up not even me pushing it
and someone sound boarded you write as
[Laughter]
okay here we go
you're ready for it I got a whole lot of
[ __ ] and they've only got so many holes
these archers gave me a lot these
archers gate I don't think hey guys
thanks for watching my twitch clips
compilation my cheeks are still a little
inflated so I can't record for a little
bit longer which is why I decide to
montage some of the better moments from
my twitch streams that I've been doing
over the past year so if you haven't
seen it there's a link in the
description below
over on twitch.tv slash markiplier where
you can check out some of my streams I
don't have a regular schedule except for
Tuesdays which today is if you're
watching this when this video first
comes out you can click on the link and
you can see Bob Wade and I do a little
bit of a podcast I think Wade's out
today so he's not there but who knows it
will be there it'll definitely be Bob
and I and somebody else we'll see check
it out links in the description thanks
so much for watching and if you want to
see more of these twitch compilations
let me know down in the comments below
and I will gladly assemble them there's
tons of clips because there's just been
a ton of laughs so thanks again and as
always don't see you in the next video
bye bye